kommen jetzt zu der der wichtigen
nachrichten verschaffen wir können jetzt
habt ihr euch jetzt mitteilen will und
zwar muss ich euch mitteilen
herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
leute den ich euch heute ein kleines
update zu dem fall geben möchte den es
auf einem kanal gehabt ich habe ja falls
ihr das video von vor zwei tagen nicht
gesehen habt einen strike auf meinem
kanal erhalten den ersten von 3 strikes
am zweiten mal eine woche ab rot sperre
beim dritten strike ist der kanal
dauerhaft gelöscht und man darf das habe
ich übrigens neu erfahren auch keine
anderen kanäle mehr aufmachen die werden
sofort mit gelöscht das heißt wenn man 3
strikes hat ist man von youtube weg
komplett und dementsprechend gereizt und
empfindlich war ich als ich meinen
ersten schreck bekommen habe als sind es
aber einige sachen passiert ich bin
sogar in kontakt mit der person die mich
gestreikt hat getreten und es gibt eine
ganz große und wichtige nachrichten
deswegen wirklich anraten dass wir bei
diesem video bis zum ende dran bleibt
denn ich werde euch die im laufe des
videos verkünden aber erst mal vorneweg
leute vettel schaut euch alter ich habe
ja ein kleine aufruf gemacht dass ihr
meinen zweiten kanal abonnieren solltet
manche verschwörungstheoretiker haben
auch gemeint die ganze aktion sei ein
fake und ich würde das nur machen um
autos auf meine zweite kanal zu bekommen
an der stelle kann ich wirklich nur
gratulieren
eine geisteskranke passives theorie
22.000 abonnenten mit einem video hatte
finde ich richtig krass vielen vielen
dank für euren support da leute und ich
bin jetzt mal für alle leute die bis
dato gedacht haben dass die ganze sache
möglicherweise einfach nur eine große
verschwörung ist und bill gates die
finger mit im spiel hat euch den e mail
verlauf zeigen mit der person die mich
gestreikt hat denn ich habe direkt am
sonntag am sonntag das ist rang bekommt
direkt am sonntag der person geschrieben
dann kam aber erst mal nichts zurück ich
dachte so etwas ist das sie hat ich will
mal ganz offen mit euch reden was ich
dachte im moment ich dachte mir okay die
person antwortet mir nicht ich habe mir
sorge macht hast du mich erpressen will
bin ich ganz ehrlich wird schauen wir
ein leute meine mail die ich geschrieben
habe und in der ich wirklich so krass
schiss gehabt habe dass irgendwas schief
ich habe geschrieben liebes team von xy
ich habe den kanal namen zensiert weil
nach wie vor der kanal haben wir damit
nichts zur sache tut es eben beim
youtube dashboard gelesen dass es so ein
programm wie man sehen kann zusammen
kanal das ist ein video von mir mit
einem schrank gelegt und wollte mich
diesbezüglich heute erfolg melden um
nachvollziehen zu können wir dazu kommt
und wie wir in dieser angelegenheit
weiter vorgehen dann kam erst mal eine
weile nichts dann kam am 9
zwei tage später mein video zu dieser
ganzen sache und über dieses video kamen
leute was ich esse
ist eigentlich schlecht ist welche seit
heute geht nicht auf diesen kanal aber
trotzdem über diesen kanal gefunden und
haben angefangen den zuzug spam und über
erst diese leute die quasi das gemacht
habe was ich eigentlich nicht wollte kam
als die aufmerksamkeit und darüber ist
erst der kanal habe von dem kanal erst
recht darauf aufmerksam geworden was da
abgeht und hat mir dann eben beschrieben
am 9 juni zwei tage später hallo
sebastian ich sehe jetzt erst deine
nachricht da ich bei meinem video gerade
für mich zu wie es bei dir von deinen
zuschauer da bin ich erst mal auf dem
video gegangen und habe es mir soeben
angeschaut jetzt kurz zu deiner male ich
habe jemanden beauftragt der überprüft
wer unsere videos in seine videos
eingebunden hat ohne uns irgendwie
erwähnt zu haben das habe ich deshalb
gemacht da unser video häufig sehr
falsch dargestellt worden ist manchmal
als extreme sucht droge also jetzt lacht
da ist vieles im falschen kontext etc so
habe ich in den letzten sieben tagen um
die 30 videos gestreikt da diese nämlich
nicht namentlich erwähnt haben da ich
nicht dachte dass ein großer kanal
irgendwie meine videos benutzt und dass
das treibt auch zu kanal sprach führen
kann werde ich selbstverständlich für
eine lösung bereit wie hast du das
gedacht liebe grüße xy weil die person
eben die den kanal betreibt geisteskrank
leute oder ich dachte so naja ich hab
mein komplettes kopfkino jetzt schon
hatte ich schon eingeschmissen da hat
mir die ganze welt geht unter
aber ein kanal wird gehört alles
geschieht dann schafft ihr person so das
ist einfach aus einem ganz anderen grund
war nicht gezielt mein video sondern
einfach weil es ja allgemein wie man
beauftragt die ausschnitte aus ihren
videos sowie blockiert und die videos
sperrt diese ausschnitte verwenden und
hat das bei 30 andere - auch gemacht
meint zwar nicht gezielt sondern nur
zufällig dabei leute checkt ja und ja
leute so wenig den kontakt mit dieser
personen gedreht und das hat tatsächlich
muss ich sagen für mich schon so ein
erster hoffnungsschimmer zwei tage hat
ihm dieses zeug rhein kann und ich mir
dachte der jetzt geht es wirklich bergab
war das der erste lichtblick für mich
weil ich kann doch mal sagen wollte ich
weiß nicht ob das wendung über wir
versuchen nicht so wichtig bin noch ein
bisschen paranoide person
aber ich dachte mir krass jetzt will mir
eine einer eindrücken das wird richtig
eklig aber es war jedoch nicht so
als weißer dann hoffentlich abschließend
beweist wenn ich euch hier mal einen
screenshot ein beziehungsweise ein bild
was beim handy von meinem bildschirm
gemacht habe und in dem moment wo ich
zum ersten mal gesehen habe da du hast
aber da seht ihr nämlich hier eine
urheberrechts verwarnung ihr seht das
datum züchter juni seht was abläuft ihr
seht das ist das richtige video ist und
dies gilt auch wenn der ganz genau
hinschaute und seht ihr den pipes der
glaube ich dass es wirklich nur ein bis
zwei sekunden
und das so sei das für mich aus in dem
moment in dem das ganze abgeben aber ja
leute kommen jetzt zu der der wichtigen
nachrichten ich erwarten verschiedene
können ich habe dich jetzt mitteilen
will
und zwar muss ich euch mitteilen dass
der strike back ist es ist wirklich
keine witze es ist wirklich kein witz
ist natürlich richtige tiefe wunde am
anfang so aussehen lassen habe als sei
es was ernstes ich wollte dafür die
spannung aufrecht erhalten diese view
wir haben es tatsächlich geschafft heute
der streik ist wieder weg und das hat
wirklich maßgeblich damit zu tun dass
wir nicht auf das gehört habe ich gesagt
nein spaß leute ich habe ja gesagt geht
nicht diesen kanal aber ich glaube
irgendwann das ganze eher kommentieren
da auch dazu beigetragen dass wir so
eine aufmerksamkeit draufgekommen ist
die art und weise wie er das video
supportet habt leute und ich konnte mich
mit dem kanal inhaber von dem anderer
kanal mega versöhnlich einigen leute ist
alles geklärt also gibt es gar keinen
grund mehr auf diesem kanal zu gehen das
ist alles easy alles entspannt hat den
streik zurückgezogen so ist weg main
kanal ist jetzt wieder clean main kanal
lebt wieder leute richtig fett auf jeden
fall können wir jetzt endlich wieder
normal weiter mit dem videos
weitermachen ich werde an diesem
wochenende auch zwei sehr geile videos
aufnehmen mit einem hilf mir darsteller
ja also macht sich da gespannt da war
richtig geil videos kommen neue projekt
hier endlich vorgestellt wie abonniert
hier um einen kanal denen es schauen wir
doch noch ein bisschen geben wird ich
bin an der stelle raus sollte noch mal
danke an euch ihr seid ihre männer und
frauen und ja macht's gut